madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
l'ancien préfet de corse bernard bonnet
à sa sortie de prison cet après-midi
accuse il serait victime d'un attentat
judiciaire il s'en prend aux ministres
de la justice et promet des coups de
théâtre à new york bernard kouchner est
nommé administrateur du kosovo c'est le
français créateur 2005 sans frontières
qui a été finalement choisi par kofi
annan secrétaire général de l'onu le
drame du téléphérique dans la vallée du
d'évoluer avec les questions autour de
l'accident la veille des manipulations
sur la cabine aurait été effectué et
puis à quelques heures du départ du tour
de france la journée s'est polarisée sur
richard virenque que la traditionnelle
visite médicale et les déclarations
acides du président du tour nous vend ce
journal avec la fracassante déclaration
de bernard bonnet après deux mois de
détention provisoire
l'ex préfet de corse qui est sorti en
fin d'après midi de la prison de la
santé s'est dit victime d'un véritable
complot judiciaire des mots qui se
veulent incisif mordant accusateurs et
notamment à l'égard du ministre de la
justice michèle fines guillaume foutra
lors de nadaillac l'ex préfet de corse a
quitté sa prison sans se cacher et
devant toute la presse
les premiers mots ont été soigneusement
posé je suis très profondément irrité de
la situation que j'ai vécu j affirme
avoir été victime d'un complot
judiciaire ou pour être plus précis
un attentat judiciaire corse commis en
bande organisée
les auteurs de cet attentat ont volé
deux mois de ma vie je trouve
inacceptable qu'une ministre de la
république madame 10 pouces puisse
bafouer
avec une telle impudence le principe de
la présomption d'innocence par les
déclarations qu'elle a faites au club de
la presse rock numéro un
je considère que de telles déclarations
sont une défaillance
je peux vous annoncer quelques quelques
coups de théâtre à brève échéance la
faire comment
libre bernard bonnet et placé sous
contrôle judiciaire il est assigné à
résidence en ile de france et doit
pointer une fois par semaine au
commissariat
le préfet n'a pas le droit de
communiquer avec les gendarmes impliqués
dans la sphère des paillotes ni avec les
témoins son premier geste d'hommes
libres
une pause café dans ce bar du 7e
arrondissement avec sa fille anne laure
et son fils stéphane extraordinaire
sentiment de liberté
quelque chose qui n'existe pas en prison
que tous ces mules et sauf et libertés
et puis en fin d'après-midi le préfet
bonnet rentrer chez lui en pain
accompagné encore par de très nombreux
journalistes le préfet bonnet a fini par
permet la porte aux journalistes
mais ce n'est que provisoirement bernard
bonnet qui avait déjà promis il ya
quelques semaines des révélations sinon
des coups de théâtre
aujourd'hui l'ex préfet de corse semble
prêt à régler ses comptes
il ya dire sa vérité michel field alors
effectivement le préfet bonnet s'attaque
essentiellement à l'appareil judiciaire
et tout d'abord au ministre de la
justice vous l'avez entendu le mrj 600
personnes elisabeth guigou bernard
bonnet lui reproche en fait des propos
qu'elle a tenus le 6 juin dernier au
club de la presse d'europe 1 et pour
bien comprendre
on va d'abord écouté ses propos je
trouve quand même bizarre hein que on
s'insurge sur la détention provisoire
quand ça concerne un pressé et que en
revanche on demande la somme paix de
braves d'honnêtes gens là contre condom
détruit les pv car year azuro vince
peut-être pas vous pas vous d'accord
vous venez de le dire mais beaucoup de
gens trouvent anormal qu'on met en
détention provisoire un prêt c est en
revanche demande qu'on met en détention
provisoire des jeunes qui souvent ont
commis des actes beaucoup moins grave
que ceux dont le prêt ces messieurs
bonnet est soupçonné et encore seulement
soupçonné puis et effectivement il n'a
pas été jugé
donc je dis moi je souhaite que la
détention provisoire soit aussi
exceptionnel que possible mais pour tout
le monde
alors effectivement bernard bonnet
reproche à la ministre de la justice
d'avoir pris position en pleine affaire
judiciaire
alors que l' enquête sur l'insomnie des
paillotes était ouverte et sans tenir
compte dit il de la présomption
d'innocence
alors quelles sont les autres sites de
bernar venet il va s'attaquer à d'autres
quand il parle par exemple l'attentât
judiciaire il parle exactement
d'attentats judiciaire en corse commis
en bande organisée les mots sont très
forts certains déjà
l'iss que les mots sont excessifs il
faut savoir que la le bernard bernard
bonnet vise la magistrature de lille il
vise d'abord le procureur général
bernard le crack est un homme avec qui
il ne s'est jamais vraiment très bien
entendu et qui a demandé l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire sur les
paillotes le préfet vise aussi le
procureur de la république d'ajaccio et
le juge d'instruction qui ont décidé son
placement en détention
bernard bonnet n'a pas pu parler pendant
deux mois alors il faut comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui il a le désir de contre
attaquer après le judiciaire il a décidé
également de s'attaquer aux politiques
il semblerait qu'il ait des choses à
dire sur l'autorité de tutelle qui l'a
encadré qui l'a soutenue pendant tous
ces mois où il a servi pendant
lesquelles il a servi à la préfecture de
corse c'est à dire les services de
matignon
merci michel field bernabeu l'aiea a nié
tout au long de sa détention provisoire
avait à avoir donné l'ordre d'incendié
les deux paillotes celle de chez francis
notamment n'avait le dernier retour sur
cette affaire qui selon l'ancien préfet
ne fait que commencer
tirez kurt et lorsqu'il ferro découvre
sa paillote incendié le 21 avril
il n'imagine pas une seconde qu'elle
tempe et va se lever
mais très vite tout se déchaîne car les
éléments retrouvés sur place jerrycans
poignard talkie walkie vont très vite
être identifié comme appartenant à trois
officiers de gendarmerie du groupement
et peloton de sécurité mesurer ces trois
hommes placés en garde à vue vont
s'embrouiller dans leurs explications
ils vont être écroué ainsi qu'un
quatrième homme blessé pendant
l'opération
mais un officier numéro deux du gps le
lieutenant-colonel cavalier a décidé de
faire part de ses soupçons au juge son
témoignage confirmée ensuite par les
quatre grades et accuse le patron de la
gendarmerie en corse le colonel mazères
d'être le donneur d'ordre le colonel
part à son tour en prison
le préfet bonnet est lui convoqué à
paris
je me suis pas triste et abasourdie
pourquoi abasourdi 28
c
c'est une affaire qui vraiment
stupéfiant mais le juge a maintenant
assez d'éléments pour soupçonner que
toutes ces décisions ont été prises en
haut lieu bernard bonnet et son
directeur de cabinet gérard pardini vont
à leur tour être mise en examen
le préfet ne reconnaît pourtant aucun
effet il n'avait pas été informé de ce
projet puis d'autres qu'on lui reproche
qu'on lui reproche
mais c'est un des vagues et encore une
fois sa demande être éclaircies c'est
peut-être d'avoir laissé se développer
autour de lui
l'idée que de telles actions après tout
était possible qui se tiendra à cette
ligne de conduite tout au long de cette
affaire
bernard bonnet incarcéré à la prison de
la santé arrivé dans un avion
ministériel il stipule dans un avion
pénitentiaire les jours plus tard le
colonel mazères est auditionné sur le
fond pour la première fois lui reconnaît
les faits a reconnu avoir donné lors
d'incendiés la paillote sur les
instructions formelles suppression
et malgré une confrontation générale
organisée à paris par le juge cambérou
chacun des trois protagonistes comme
désormais sur ses positions
gérard pardini et le colonel mazères ont
été libérée il ya trois jours
bernard bonnet est resté en prison
durant deux mois le deuxième titre de ce
journal avec en toute fin de journée la
nomination de bernard kouchner qui
devient administrateur du kosovo celui
qui est actuellement secrétaire d'état à
la santé qui se bat sur le terrain
humanitaire depuis tant d'années a été
donc finalement choisi par le secrétaire
général des nations unies à new york en
direct dominique derda d'après vos
informations
quels sont les éléments qui ont joué en
faveur de bernard kouchner face aux
autres candidats
mais écoutez béatrice bernard kofi annan
pardon chercher pour ce poste un homme
ou une femme d'expérience d'expérience
politique mais aussi des expériences de
terrain un gestionnaire quelqu'un qui
pourrait être efficace tout de suite
ce portrait évidemment pour les français
bien c'était celui de bernard kouchner
qui est fort occupé les fonctions
d'administrateur de l'onu au kosovo il
avait bernard kouchner un rival très
sérieux qui est l'actuel ministre de
l'environnement des pays bas jan aps
roncq
mais ce qui a sans doute permis à
bernard kouchner de l'emporter au delà
des pressions constantes de la france
pour que ce soit lui qui ait ce poste
et bien c'est justement cette expérience
de terrain on connaît le passé de
bernard kouchner on connaît aussi son
extraordinaire dynamisme ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que jusqu'à la dernière
minute jusqu'à tout à l'heure il ya à
peine deux heures eh bien le suspens
restait entier
kofi annan s'était bien gardé de laisser
fuir la moindre information et jusqu'à
la dernière minute donc personne n'a su
lequel des deux aurait les faveurs du
secrétaire général des nations unies ce
que je peux vous dire aussi c'est que
bernard kouchner devrait très vite
prendre ses fonctions parce qu'une fois
encore il y a urgence
il ya urgence à administrer à diriger ce
véritable protectorat qui est devenue
maintenant la province du kosovo
merci à dominique derda jacques chirac
s'est aussitôt réjoui du choix de kofi
annan a indiqué l'elysée et pour sa part
lionel jospin a déclaré que la
nomination de bernard kouchner était un
honneur pour la france je vous propose
de l'écouter
je pense que c'est un honneur pour notre
pays que
le secrétaire général des nations unies
monsieur kofi annan et j'ai choisi pour
son représentant au kosovo un français
c'est aussi un honneur que ce soit un
membre de mon gouvernement qui a été
choisie je pense que bernard kouchner a
toutes les qualités
par son engagement par sa formation par
son expérience pour remplir cette
mission qui sera en même temps une
mission très difficile
bernard kouchner à la fois politique
mais aussi homme de terrain c'est lui
qui a fondé il ya près de 30 ans
médecins sans frontières son combat a
toujours été celui du droit d'ingérence
humanitaire
retour sur l'itinéraire de ce médecin
engagé ilan à maurice du biafra aux
balkans en passant par la somalie
bernard kouchner a été présent sur tous
les fronts humanitaires des trente
dernières années
président de médecins sans frontières
puis de médecins du monde jusqu'en 1988
il a été l'une des figures de proue des
french doctors
mais la politique ne l'a jamais tout à
fait quitté l'ancien étudiant communiste
sera successivement ministre de michel
rocard edith cresson et pierre bérégovoy
puis lionel jospin
un ministre un peu trop médiatique au
goût de certains
son apparition en somalie sac de riz sur
l'épaule sous l'oeil des caméras lui
sera reprochée amateurs de coups d'éclat
il est l'un des artisans de la visite de
françois mitterrand dans sarajevo en
guerre en juin 1992
depuis deux ans on entendait un peu
moins il s'en fout un peu à l'étroit
dans son costume de secrétaire d'état à
la santé sous la tutelle est dans
l'ombre de martine aubry avec ce poste
d'administrateur de l'onu au kosovo
bernard kouchner promoteur du droit
d'ingérence humanitaire retrouve à
presque 60 ans l'action internationale
avec l'espoir de devenir un jour
secrétaire général de l'onu
bernard kouchner aura donc pour tâche au
kosovo de mettre en place tous les
dispositifs au plan civil pour assurer
la paix dans la province
une tâche ô combien difficile avec
notamment ces affrontements entre
communautés serbe et albanaise qui ont
pris une nouvelle tournure aujourd'hui à
mitrovica dans le secteur géré par les
forces françaises l'arrestation d'un
milicien serbe a failli tourner à
l'affrontement massif sur place a
mentionné bruno livertout cet homme
barbu qui filtrent les entrées de la
partie majoritairement serbe de
mitrovica a été arrêté ce matin par les
gendarmes
il s'appelle dragan mariano zik il est
filmé ici le 23 juin en train de
contrôler un journaliste
les soldats de la kfor le soupçonnait
d'être le chef d'une milice de 250
jeunes serbes comme c'était prévisible
son interpellation a provoqué une
manifestation ce matin du côté terme de
la ville la circulation a été bloquée
sur le pont les gendarmes estimant que
c'était le seul moyen d'éviter les
affrontements
tant que la manifestation n'était pas
disperser on règle un problème à la fois
quand ça sera dispersée ici on vient
faire la même chose car de l'autre côté
du pont les albanais eux aussi se sont
regroupés ils reprochent aux français
d'être les alliés des serbes et de les
empêcher d'aller de l'autre côté où
pourtant certains habitent ils leur
reprochent de n'avoir pas su éradiquer
ces milices terme qui leur interdisent
l'accès à leurs maisons
l'otan a réussi à obtenir le retrait de
8 40 ont mis moins claire policier du
kosovo et boum et même à en finir avec
quelques centaines l'émission si loin
c'est là où ils se plaignent des
français auprès de deux membres de la
future police de l'onu même
l'arrestation de dragan ne les calmes
pas cellules qui a été jugée tous ces
massacres en touche et incendie le
commandant de zone de loups checa arrive
finalement sur les lieux
il prend brièvement la parole pour
ramener le calme
rappelé aux albanais présent leur
engagement de respecter les accords
conclus et procède lui-même à la
dispersion
quant à dragan le chef milicien sert
présumés ils restent en garde à vue
selon la procédure française
il n'a pas encore pu voir les avocats
car lorsque les avocats ont essayé de
passer le barrage tout à l'heure ils ont
été accueillis à coups de pierres mais
je pense que cet après midi lorsqu'elle
attention les esprits se sont apaisés
nous pourrons amener deux avocats le
rencontrer c'est tout à fait normal et
légal
mais en fin d'après midi les avocats
refusaient de franchir à nouveau le fond
les serbes aussi accusent les français
de ne pas savoir les protéger retour en
france avec les larmes et la colère dans
la vallée du dévoluy 24 heures après le
drame du téléphérique qui je vous le
rappelle a fait 20 morts
une chapelle ardente a été installée la
nuit dernière le recueillement des
enfants du pays didier guyot thierry
simonet
il en a été ainsi que la journée seuls
ou en petits groupes des amis des
membres de la famille sont venus se
recueillir devant les derniers cercueil
13 ans prend la nef de l'église puis une
à une la plupart des familles sont
repartis dans leurs villages en monte
avec elle
la dépouille mortelle de leurs proches
pour les 450 habitants de sainte etienne
en dévoluy
le traumatisme est réel ils sont morts
au service de l'état l'état nous doit
des comptes l'état transgene le doigt
des quant à moi à nous tous comme des
partenaires à toute la montagne
française
il faut qu'on sache ce qui s'est passé
la nuit dernière les familles effondrées
ont été invités à se rendre sur les
lieux de la catastrophe afin de
reconnaître les corps un moment
insoutenable dans la nuit un office
religieux a été célébré
mais difficile pour les prêtres de la
vallée de trouver les mots qui a 13
j'ai employé aucun mot j'ai écouté quoi
que vous disiez les familles qu'est ce
que vous voulez qu'elle me disait vous
dise
ne me parlez pas de dieu une famille l'a
dit savez je ne parlais pas de dieu les
sapeurs-pompiers du village ont bien du
mal aussi à masquer leurs émotions en
arrivant d'amour il n'y avait plus rien
à faire en étant le premier arrivé sur
les lieux le premier constat qu'on fait
c'est premièrement d'avoir vingt
victimes toutes décédées
ce qui est terrible pour les sapeurs
pompiers parce que
notre but c'est pas notre but c'est de
sauver des vies ce passait pas
uniquement de gérer l'amour demain matin
dans la plus stricte intimité une
cérémonie sera célébrée afin d'enterrer
les trois habitants du village qui ont
péri dans l'accident
voyons maintenant les hypothèses qui
pourraient expliquer l'accident du
téléphérique avec cette nouvelle donne
et des manipulations autour de la cabine
aurait eu lieu la veille du drame et le
technicien qui en étaient chargés mort
dans l'accident le point sur l'enquêté
et les questions que l'on se pose
jacques cardoze vincent deux ombres si
les constatations ne sont pas terminées
il en est une qui ne fait aucun doute
le câble tracteur visiblement affaissé à
jouer un rôle essentiel dans cet
accident
deuxième certitude des travaux de
maintenance ont bien eu lieu la veille
du drame
mais y at-il un lien de cause à effet
c'est ce que va tenter de savoir
l'expert judiciaire nommé par le
procureur
un expert présent sur les lieux cet
après midi à ses côtés les gendarmes de
la section de recherches de grenoble
photographier ce qu'il reste de
l'appareil
c'est seulement après cette première
phase d' enquête que l'on pourra tenter
d'expliquer les circonstances de ce
drame un drame que l'on ne comprend pas
particulièrement dans ce hameau situé au
plus près de l'accident
je pense que nos jeunes qui étaient
fiables à le transporter des charges
beaucoup plus lourd dans un matériel qu
avec les bâtiments avec les chargés de
personnes vous l'avez vu transporter des
charges plus importantes que une
vingtaine de personnes qui ont commis un
crime en tv du sima du sable du variés
pour la construction au tueur cet homme
emprunte est souvent sauté des cabines
ému d'avoir perdu des connaissances sans
doute aussi dit avoir échappé
les circonstances de l'accident laisse à
penser que la belle aurait débuté une
marche arrière
ici au bas du dernier tronçon après 15
minutes d'un trajet qui dure 25 minutes
du pylône trois hauts pylônes 2 ce
dernier aurait fait office de tremplin
une course folle vers le vide enfin il
est quasiment acquis qu'une deuxième
personne se trouvait à proximité de la
cabine du conducteur
situé 1400 mètres plus bas
un homme qui a assisté impuissant à
l'accident voilà des éléments
d'information qui ne sont pour le moment
que des pistes de travail et en direct
de saint-etienne non dévalués viendra
gadret quelques nouvelles précisions
concernant les investigations en cours
avec les questions qui se posent que se
posent les enquêteurs autour du câble
qui tracte la cabine effectivement
béatrice ce soir l'enquète semble se
focaliser autour de ce câble tracteur ce
câble qui comme son nom l'indiqué tracts
is la cabine vers le sommet alors en
fait la cabine est accroché avec à ce
câble avec une fixation une sorte de
mâchoire qui enserre le câble on sait
maintenant donc que la cabine est parti
à reculons qu'elle a glissé sur ce cap
ce qui veut dire que la mâchoire ce
serait desserrer la question est de
savoir pourquoi la première hypothèse qu
au cours de l'opération de maintenance
qui est donc eu lieu la veille du drame
la mâchoire aurait été mal resserré
deuxième hypothèse hypothèses prises ce
soir très au sérieux
le câble tracteur serait reparti en
arrière dans un premier temps à très
grande vitesse pour une raison inconnue
puis se serait bloqué brutalement
peut-être parce que les sécurités du
téléphérique ont joué et que la machine
a stoppé et sous l'effet de ce choc très
brutal la cabine la fixation de la
cabine n'aurait pas résisté et la cabine
aurait glissé à reculons avant de
s'écraser
c'est une hypothèse sur laquelle les
enquêteurs travaillent ce soir mais je
dois vous dire que les très difficile
d'avoir des informations fiables
officielle dans la mesure où du côté des
gendarmes comme du côté des autorités
judiciaires c'est le mutisme le plus
complet
merci gadret j'en viens maintenant au
tour de france et à cette journée
entièrement tournée polarisé autour de
richard virenque à la veille du départ
les vivats des supporteurs les
déclarations très réservé du directeur
du tour et l'arrivée du champion
cycliste pour la traditionnelle visite
médicale nathanaël de rincquesen alain
poirier
depuis ce matin richard virenque
cristallise toute l'attention des médias
voilà comment une simple visite médicale
s'est transformé en foire d'empoigné
virenque va finalement rejoindre le
centre médical pour le traditionnel
contrôle aucun problème le coureur de
l'équipe polti est apte à participer au
tour de france 99 une frénésie
médiatique
voilà sans doute ce que voulait éviter
jean marie leblanc en privant richard
virenque de tour de france lui c'est y
en a décidé autrement
les autres coureurs ont apprécié je suis
pas juge suis pas directeur du tour de
france ni présidente du celi donc ils
prennent des décisions à eux de les
assumer et on verra dans dans les trois
semaines qui viennent si les décisions
qu'ils ont prises sont bonnes ou
mauvaises
ce matin lors de sa conférence de presse
jean marie leblanc à son tour s'est
laissé aller à un petit commentaire
concernant une éventuelle victoire de
richard virenque à paris si l'hypothèse
que vous évoquez ce rêve se réalisait je
pense que ce serait tout de même un
camouflet pour d'autres coureurs et
d'autres équipes effectivement ça ne
serait pas la meilleure chose qui puisse
arriver aux sports cyclistes actuelle il
ya quelques minutes le patron du tour a
réuni tous les coureurs et les
directeurs sportifs dans une grande
salle à l'abri des regards indiscrets et
des journalistes en compagnie de jean
claude killy tu es de aïn verbruggen le
président de l'uci
jean marie leblanc voulait une dernière
fois précise et à toutes les équipes
combien ce tour de france était
important pour l'avenir du cyclisme
les chars virenque bloqués dans les
embouteillages est arrivé bon dernier
mais il est arrivé au chapitre
judiciaire le procès de jacques
crozemarie retardé après le coup de
théâtre hier en pleine audience révélant
l'existence d'un compte en suisse de
l'ancien patron de l'arc le compte rendu
avec dominique wernert et maxime le chef
jacques crozemarie rattrapé par son
compte bancaire suisse l'ex président de
l'arc ne l'avait jamais révélé après
tout avoir un million quatre cent mille
francs en terres helvétiques ce n'est
pas un crime
un compte une somme qui n'apparaissait
pas dans le volumineux dossier de l'arc
jusqu'à hier ce renseignement tardif
venant d'un jus
suisse 1 dispose la défense de jacques
crozemarie pour ses avocats le fait que
l'accusation ait révélé l'existence de
ce compte à la veille de leur plaidoirie
est un procédé déloyal ça pour but de
bien entendu de porter atteinte à ses
droits en essayant de justifier l'image
qu'on a créés on a fait un mannequin
qu'on appelait crozemarie et il est pas
mauvais qu'il est en plus un compte en
suisse
ça ajoute je n'étais pas au courant de
la gestion de ce compte insiste à
l'audience jacques crozemarie les fonds
en chêne l'accusé proviennent de ma mère
un peu facile rétorque que la partie
civile
lorsqu on dissimule les choses dit
lorsqu'on me suis vu quelque chose
d'aussi important d'un compte en banque
en suisse dans une telle affaire c'est
qu'on sait que les fonds sont suspects
et on peut le penser d'autant plus que
ce compte a été ouvert à une époque où
la cour des comptes effectivement a
commencé son enquête
un procès où décidément tout peut
arriver d'un côté un président qui lâche
à l'intention d'un jacques crozemarie
arrogant le crédit de patience du
tribunal est épuisé de l'autre jacques
crozemarie qui note en main veut régler
ses comptes
il doit désormais attendre jusqu'à jeudi
prochain dernier jour du procès pour
s'exprimer en dernier
à moins que d'ici là bien sûr un nouvel
incident n'intervienne d'actualité à
l'étranger avec l'accord de paix en
question en irlande du nord de nouvelles
tractations se poursuivent à l'heure
qu'il est après plusieurs jours déjà des
discussions marathon les premiers
ministres anglais irlandais tony blair
et bertière mettent tout leur poids dans
la balance pour tenter une nouvelle fois
de sauver l'accord de paix un seul
objectif trouver coûte que coûte un
compromis entre les unionistes et le
thin fine en turquie après la
condamnation à mort d'abdullah ocalan
deux attentats l'un dans l'est du pays
qui a fait six morts et huit blessés
l'autre à istanbul une bombe à
retardement placée dans un café a
explosé à un inconnu aurait déposé un
paquet sous une table selon des témoins
la police turque indique avoir arrêté
dix personnes soupçonnées de préparer
des attentats
il n'est juste pas à moscou a rencontré
ce matin boris eltsine une rencontre en
tête à tête avec le chef du kremlin
au coeur des discussions des relations
franco-russes le premier ministre qui
s'est entretenu ensuite avec quelques
unes des figures marquantes de la scène
politique russe alban nicosie jacques
grégoire
une gerbe de fleurs sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu
geste protocolaire passage obligé de
toute visite officielle avec cette fois
ci un peu plus de signification que
d'habitude en tout cas pour moscou la
crise du kosovo a dégradé l'atmosphère
des relations franco-russes lionel
jospin le sait l'enjeu du voyage c'est
la confiance
ça a été une forme d'épreuve mais comme
le fait d'avoir à faire la guerre en
europe
près d'un demi siècle après la deuxième
guerre mondiale a été une épreuve et un
motif de débats pour nos propres
opinions publiques
on peut donc comprendre que c était
également le cas en russie ce matin en
rencontrant à boris eltsine
particulièrement en forme le par presque
alerte et le propos assuré lionel jospin
a eu la satisfaction d'entendre le
numéro un russe saluer symboliquement la
france un pays avec lequel la russie
entretient des relations privilégiées
comprendre les divergences appartient au
passé les deux pays travaillent
désormais de concert pour établir la
paix au kosovo notamment dans la zone a
bis l'étranger dans ce contexte de
rapprochement entre la france et la
russie
la nomination de bernard kouchner ici ne
surprend personne
on croit même savoir que boris eltsine
n'était pas du tout opposé en france
chaque année 800 mille personnes
contractent une infection à l'hôpital
c'est à dire une maladie nosocomiale
la cour de cassation a décidé cette
semaine que les médecins seraient
désormais responsable de ces infections
une décision qui permettra entre autres
aux malades d'être indemnisé benoît
thevenet stéphane haumant quelques
minutes avant l'opération le chirurgien
badigeonne le corps de cette patiente de
désinfectant le but éviter que des
germes présents sur la peau ne rentre à
l'intérieur de l'organisme provoquant
une infection nosocomiale la salle les
instruments sont eux aussi aseptisé mais
sur une table d'opération ou dans un lit
d'hôpital
impossible de supprimer tous les
microbes et bactéries le risque
infectieux zéro n'existe pas parce que
les malades eux-mêmes héberge des
bactéries berges des microbes et peuvent
perdre et
action à partir de leurs propres de
leurs propres termes
et cela on ne pourra jamais empêcher
complètement mais mardi la cour de
cassation a jugé que les médecins
étaient responsables une infection
contractée à l'hôpital
même s'il n'y avait pas foule les
médecins des cliniques privées
particulièrement visés par cet arrêt
craignent une américanisation de la
relation médecin patient
les malades les plus fragiles donc à
risque comme les diabétiques les fumeurs
ou les personnes âgées pourraient être
écartés de leur clientèle le problème
qui en supportera la conséquence d'un
finalement massa sera le malade car on
lui dira écoutez monsieur est un risque
d'avoir un problème
nos assurances ne veulent plus nous
assurer pendant sa pratique de chirurgie
ou un certain type de fonctionnement
nous sommes désolés pour vous ne peut
pas vous opérer et ça se passe déjà aux
états unis dans un certain nombre de
charges
mais d'un autre côté il s'agit d'une
véritable avancée pour les patients en
cas d'infections contractées à l'hôpital
ils pourront obtenir réparation
aujourd'hui on a cet arrêt de cassation
qui va permettre à toutes les victimes
d'infections nosocomiales de se faire
indemniser
normalement le problème est maintenant
entre les mains des pouvoirs publics
pour la mise en place d'un fonds
d'indemnisation qui puisse permettre aux
médecins de continuer à exercer sans
avoir à payer des primes d'assurance qui
vont forcément s'envoler depuis des
années différents projets de loi
concernant un fonds d'indemnisation
attendent dans des cartons la décision
de la cour de cassation devrait
permettre de faire bouger les choses
pour trouver une solution conciliant
garantie de réparation pour les malades
et sérénité pour les praticiens
dès aujourd'hui vous êtes nombreux à
prendre la route des départs en vacances
la plus grande prudence une nouvelle
fois recommandé aux automobilistes la
sécurité en question et en priorité sur
tous les axes routiers en particulier
sur la nationale 10 tristement célèbre
pour ses accidents à répétition dans les
landes on a enfin pris le problème à
bras le corps en transformant la
nationale coupé par de nombreuses
intersections en autoroute
david base et marie pierre cassignard
demain dans les landes c'en iv vont
emprunter à grande vitesse la nationale
10 une vraie fausse autoroute avec ces
carrefours dangereux bains de mer là on
a peut-être fait venir
voter l'entrée de route
un carrefour le 13 août 97
un camion de maïs percute un bus
portugais huit morts 23 blessés
je suis obligé de remonter les axes pour
les x men depuis trente personnes de la
direction départementale de l'équipement
travaille exclusivement à la
transformation de la nationale en
autoroute prévu pour 2003
les premiers travaux visent à sécuriser
l'axé routier
cette route débouché il ya quelques mois
ou semaines directement sur la nationale
la représentation de ce qui se passait
jusqu'à il ya quelques mois où on avait
lorsqu'il 70,5 c'est à peu prêt direct
sur cette nationale
au jour d'aujourd'hui une cinquantaine a
été supprimé il ne reste quasiment plus
que les carrefours 20 carrefour
extrêmement dangereux restent en place
en attendant la construction de ponts la
préfecture vient à peine de décider
l'interdiction des tracteurs et des
moissonneuses batteuses sur la nationale
10 pour changer la triste réputation des
landes le département vient de lancer
une initiative pilote allumer les p2i
aurions économisé près de 900 morts en
france
on a l'expérience d'autres et à d'autres
pays aux états unis notamment la
californie qui portent en plus
ensoleillé que le sud à vence
ils ont obtenu des résultats
considérablement les feux de croisement
déjà un automobiliste sur deux
observerait l'expérience pilote et si ça
marche je vois effectivement pas
pourquoi on déciderait pas d'appliquer
sa de manière réglementaire au niveau
national mais bon que ce soient
réglementaires ou sous forme de
préconisation officielle qui compte dès
que le conducteur se persuader que
mesure est utile ce soir les premiers
vacanciers arriveront dans les landes
encore une fois la vigilance sera la
seule garantie de sécurité routière qui
a été sportive avec deux mâles le départ
du tour de france voyant quels sont les
temps forts du parcours de la grande
boucle avec bien évidemment ces étapes
de montagne florent gautreau philippe
deslandes
voici le seul rescapé du podium 98
l'américain bobby joe lynch est arrivé
ce matin auréolé d'un statut de favori
dans un tour 99 qui en manque
cruellement
bjarne riis vainqueur en 96 jan ullrich
vainqueur en 1997 et marco pantani
vainqueur 98 sont absents pour la
première fois depuis 43 ans il n'y aura
pas d'anciens vainqueurs au départ le
départ justement sera donné au puy du
fou comme il y a 6 ans pour le prologue
et les sept premières étapes d'abord
dans l'ouest de la france puis dans le
nord-est seront comme d'habitude
réservée aux sprinteurs le sprinter de
tvm playe les vingt-sept absents les
favoris pour les victoires d'étapes
seront dans tripoli ni tom steels et
irritable
après le contre-la-montre de mais c'est
une première journée de repos les
coureurs s'attaque à la montagne et
notamment l'alpe d'huez pour l'une des
trois arrivées en altitude sans pente
amis la course est ouverte mais on voit
mal comment le maillot de meilleur
grimpeur pour échapper à richard
virenque le dernier contre-la-montre au
futuroscope pourrait avoir son
importance mais difficile de dire qui
sera en jaune à paris
après plus de 3600 km le tour aura
trouvé un successeur à pantani
on parle de bobby julich de michael
bogaert
mais depuis quelques jours tout le monde
pense à richard virenque
en direct et du puy-du-fou florent
gautreau ces demandes de mal au coup
d'envoi du prologue de ce tour de france
qui a fait tant parler ces dernières
semaines on a peu évoqué le sport et les
sportifs
oui c'est vrai on a beaucoup parlé des
absents des revenants mais on n'a pas
parlé de l'épreuve elle-même et demain
il y aura bien 180 coureurs au départ du
prologue de six kilomètres vicent ici
autour du site du puy du fou et les
spectateurs devront même attendre 18h59
pour voir s'élancer à richard virenque
mais avant le prologue demain matin il y
aura un épisode important avec les
contrôles sanguins que devront souris
subir tous les coureurs du tour tous
absolument tous et c'est une première
dans l'histoire du tour de france une
première qui évidemment à mettre au
crédit de la lutte contre le dopage
dernière information à noter aujourd'hui
la présence d'annie verbruggen président
de l'union cycliste internationale il
est sur le tour il a parlé avec jean
marie leblanc on sait depuis la sphère
viande que les deux hommes ne
s'apprécient guère
mais la présence de verbruggen sur le
tour de france est incontestablement un
signe d'apaisement avant le départ qui
aura donc lieu demain
merci florent gautreau une équipe de
rêve de basket qui n'a pas été portés
par la victoire d'hier les tricolores se
sont fait mener par les espagnols 70 à
ce qui n'empêchera pas je vous le
rappelle la france de participer aux
olympiques de sydney christelle bertrand
tous soudés ce soir ce sont les
espagnols qui vont faire la fête ils ont
gagné leur place en finale face à des
français submergé la première mi temps
est équilibrée la deuxième est
catastrophique côté tricolore ils sont
maladroits à trois points et les
espagnols dominent au rebot les français
n'arrivent pas à trouver la solution ni
en attaque ni en défense
des espagnols ont eu jusqu'à 13 points
d'avancé les français ont un temps de
retard sur tous les ballons beaucoup
leur file entre les doigts
peu à peu l'équipe de france tente de
refaire son retard laurent foirest
réussi le chou du désespoir mais ce soir
les espagnols ont mieux pris leur chance
il s'impose 70 à 63 en finale ils
rencontreront le vainqueur du match qui
oppose la yougoslavie à l'italie la
france a quand même fait parler d'elle
pendant ce championnat d'europe et
remplisse son principal objectif
décrocher la qualification pour les jeux
olympiques
et puis du tennis à wimbledon il n'y a
plus de français en lice nathalie
tauziat et cédric pioline se sont fait
éliminer en quarts de finale c'est la
fin de ce journal je vous en rappelle
les principaux titres
l'ancien préfet de corse bernard bonnet
à sa sortie de prison cet après-midi
accuse il serait victime d'un attentat
judiciaire il s'en prend ministre de la
justice et promet des coups de théâtre à
new york bernard kouchner est nommé
administrateur du kosovo c'est le
français créateur de médecins sans
frontières qui a été finalement choisi
par kofi annan le secrétaire général de
l'onu dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet puis le point route de valérie
maurice 20h50 votre série urgences vers
11h25 le dernier journal d'être mettait
je vous retrouve demain dès 13 heures je
vous remercie de l'attention
excellente soirée sur france 2